Trascrizione: Elena de' Michieli Vitturi
Revisore: Denise RQ
Perché mai una persona
vorrebbe lavorare gratis per un anno,
seguita da una squadra di persone
che pure loro lavorano gratis per un anno,
per fare un evento che dura un giorno
e senza essere
in generale nemmeno dei
professionisti, organizzatori di eventi?
Perché? Perché farlo se le regole
impediscono di trarne profitti economici?
Le regole dicono: non può esserci
un profit generato da questo evento e,
se generi un profit, è un errore,
dunque devi prendere quel denaro,
quel surplus, e donarlo a una ONG.
Quando la conferenza californiana TED,
4 anni e mezzo fa,
ha deciso di fare un esperimento
assolutamente marginale e pensò:
e se provassimo a creare
un concetto di licenza locale,
se mettessimo una X vicino
a queste tre magiche lettere TED
e dessimo ad alcune persone impegnate
con la loro comunità la possibilità
di creare unpiccolo evento allo stile TED?
Magari, chissà, 10, 20, 30 città
potrebbero anche essere interessate.
E dopo 4 anni e mezzo, sentite un po':
dopo 4 anni e mezzo sono stati organizzati
8.200 eventi TEDx in 153 Paesi,
in 2.083 città, con un pubblico
di 1.200.100 persone,
più 480 oggi che siete voi,
33.300 conferenze in video
viste nella rete 150 milioni di volte.
Oggi, per esempio, noi siamo
qui a Como ma non siamo soli,
siamo legati impercettibilmente
nello spirito con altri 22 eventi,
pensate che si svolgono oggi,
9 novembre, nei 5 continenti:
in Pakistan, in Trinidad di Tobago,
in Sudan, in Kenya,
negli Stati Uniti, negli Emirati, in Perù,
in Romania, in Giappone, in Taiwan.
Ma questi sono solo i numeri e i numeri
solo spiegano una parte di questo fenomeno
Ci sono delle altre cose che vanno
capite, esplorate e sono lo spirito,
lo spirito speciale legato
a questa piattaforma,
che è sì una piattaforma di licenze,
ci sono altri programmi di licenze,
ma come questa non c'è nessuna.
Questa è una cosa veramente speciale.
Tanto per cominciare,
questi contenuti come li definiremmo?
Cosa c'entra un elefante
che corre follemente per una foresta
con un bambino sindaco?
Cosa c'entra un errore della genetica
con una moto elettrica
che va da Shanghai a Milano?
Cosa c'entrano
i Paesi democratici con la religione?
Cosa c'entrano tutte queste cose?
E il pubblico come lo definiremmo?
Perché anche il pubblico
è abbastanza indefinibile
in tutti questi eventi.
Perché io non vi conosco,
ma basta guardarvi
per capire che non siete
un gruppo di professionisti
di una, diciamo, industria o un'altra.
Basta guardarvi per capire che non siete
nessun gregge in particolare.
A me piace questa piattaforma
in special modo,
perché tutti possono scegliere di fare
in questo programma TEDx
quello che vogliono.
Possono decidere di prendere
la leadership, chiedere una licenza,
che è gratuita,
chiunque in questa sala la può chiedere.
E diventare organizzatori,
prendersi quella responsabilità
e lavorare gratis durante un anno.
Ma possono anche decidere
di essere co-organizzatori
e dare una mano a curare,
a commissariare questi programmi
così complicati da creare,
o possono essere volontari,
lavorare tutto l'anno come volontari,
come tutti quelli
che hanno aiutato l'evento di oggi,
o essere volontari un giorno
e venire qua oggi ad aiutare
a che tutta questa logistica
complicata funzioni.
Ma poi possono anche decidere
di essere pubblico,
un pubblico attivo, come voi,
che avete sentito queste cose
e nelle pause avete cominciato
a discutere e stasera a cena,
anche stasera discuterete e domani,
oppure potete decidere
di non venire nemmeno qui e vedere,
perché molti degli eventi TEDx
sono proiettati gratuitamente in streaming
e di vederlo da casa.
E poi potete anche decidere
di nemmeno fare quello,
ma aspettare che tutti questi video
vengano pubblicati gratuitamente in rete
e vederli comodamente a casa vostra.
Ma c'è anche di più
ed è che questo programma arriva
così capillarmente vicino a tante
comunità che, se avete un'idea
che vale la pena diffondere, potreste
addirittura voi essere speaker.
Avete un'idea che vale la pena diffondere?
Perché questo programma
è anche per questo.
E questo programma è anche per bambini.
Per esempio,
oggi abbiamo avuto un esempio
di un bambino che ha le idee chiare,
ma non è l'unico.
Sapete che un certo numero
di eventi TEDx nel mondo
sono organizzati da bambini per bambini?
E il prossimo weekend, 16-17 novembre,
che è prossimo al 20 di novembre,
giorno mondiale dell'infanzia
organizzato dalle Nazioni Unite,
o lanciato dalle Nazioni Unite,
100 eventi TEDx nel mondo sono organizzati
da bambini e ragazzi per bambini e ragazzi
Potete vedere tutte le ritrasmissioni
di tutti questi eventi
in una pagina speciale creata
che si chiama TEDx Youth Day.
Poi ci sono le Università,
e l'Università è un posto ideale
per fare un TEDx,
infatti l'evento, diciamo la piattaforma,
è cresciuta anche grazie
alle tantissime Università
che hanno cominciato ad organizzare
eventi TEDx nei loro campus.
Perché un'Università
è un luogo pieno di conoscenze
che stanno aspettando
di essere messe in comune,
che stanno aspettando di essere regalate,
perché sapete
che noi organizzatori siamo obbligati
a diffondere questi contenuti.
La licenza è gratis, ma siamo obbligati
a prendere tutti questi ponenti,
metterli in un video
e poi circolare questo video
gratuitamente al mondo.
E non è facile fare un TEDx
in un'Università.
Ci sono un sacco
di difficoltà burocratiche,
soprattutto se sei uno studente
e hai bisogno dell'appoggio di tutti.
Eppure 100 e 100 eventi TEDx
nelle Università.
E poi ci sono colleghi
che si mettono veramente in problemi.
Per esempio TEDx
nelle istituzioni penitenziarie,
dove il ponente chi è?
Il recluso, che per un giorno
diventa un'altra cosa
e insegna al mondo tutte quelle cose
che ha imparato stando lì.
C'è un evento negli Stati Uniti
che si chiama TEDx Marion Correctional
che si fa in un'istituzione penitenziaria
dell'Ohio,
dove i ponenti sono i reclusi,
le guardie e le loro famiglie.
Ma altri si mettono
in problemi ancora peggiori,
per esempio TEDx Maastricht.
Sapete dove si fa un TEDx Maastricht?
In un treno, nel treno
che va da Maastricht ad Amsterdam
e gli speaker parlano
nei differenti vagoni.
E poi si è anche fatto
un TEDx nell'Everest,
in un campo base a 21.000 metri o piedi,
signori e signore,
per cui, chi era il pubblico?
Bè, gli scalatori e gli sherpa
che passavano da quelle parti. Sapete che?
In maggio è stato fatto.
Sapete che il 2013
è il 60° anniversario della scalata
all'Everest, è questo il motivo.
Forse un evento one-shot,
ma poi ci sono quelli di TEDx Antarctica
che fanno l'evento sul ghiaccio,
sulla superficie del ghiaccio.
Hanno già fatto 2 o 3 edizioni.
Poi però ci sono anche i problemi:
c'è gente che per fare questo evento
veramente si mette in problemi,
con la polizia.
TEDx Bagdad, TEDx Kabul
e quest'anno in Sudan,
in TEDx Khartoum, sapete
che la polizia è entrata?
È un Paese che non starà sicuramente
nella mappa dei Paesi democratici
spiegati dal collega.
È entrata la polizia a metà dell'evento
e ha sganciato la corrente dell'hotel
dove si stava svolgendo l'evento,
per impedire loro di continuarlo
fino alla fine.
Sapete che si fanno TEDx nei quartieri
più poveri del mondo,
nelle periferie
delle grandi città africane,
nelle favelas, dove sicuramente
non ci sono i mezzi
per avere un cestino
e un panino così buono,
dove è impossibile fare
queste lettere di legno,
dove la marca si fa ritagliando
il cartone,
o con uno spray rosso sulle pareti?
A volte si fanno TEDx
nei villaggi dell'India
dove non c'è elettricità
e non si sa bene come lo fanno,
ma lo fanno e accudono migliaia
di donne vestite di nero e coperte,
a discutere, a unirsi con altre persone.
Perché oggi qualcuno ha detto:
"non mi importa ciò che la tecnologia
arriverà ad ottenere,
perché al finale io mi voglio unire
fisicamente con altre persone".
Dunque, perché facciamo questo?
Ah, e perché lo sponsorizziamo,
per esempio?
Perché sponsorizziamo
un evento come questo
quando gli spazi commerciali
sono così limitati
ed è assolutamente proibito unire
la parte commerciale
dalla parte di contenuto e la parte
sponsoring deve essere così discreta?
Perché tante aziende del mondo
hanno deciso di unirsi a questo movimento?
Sapete che in Pakistan
una coppia che si doveva sposare
ha scoperto che la data del suo matrimonio
coincideva con l'evento TEDx e hanno
cambiato la data del loro matrimonio?
Anche succedono queste cose.
Sapete che c'è gente in paesi e in città
dove avere un'entrata
ad un evento come questo
è una cosa così ambita e così desiderata,
che se uno è riuscito ad andare
un anno, poi l'anno dopo,
se ha il biglietto, lo cede
a un'altra persona che non è mai stata?
E allora perché? Girolamo, perché?
Perché lo facciamo?
Perché tantissima gente fa questo tipo
di cose straordinarie?
Perché... non lo sappiamo.
Veramente non lo sappiamo,
perché non c'è una risposta razionale,
non c'è una risposta logica,
è una specie di enigma.
È la forza della X. Grazie mille.
(Applausi)